[Musik]
hey lieben heute gibt es wieder etwas
aus kies buck schule wir machen heute
ein schokoladen bis geboten und ihr
wisst ja mein bis geboten ist echt so
das nonplusultra unter den rezepten weil
es einfach immer gelingen sich ist
bekommen wir so viele fotos von euch
zugeschickt und heute gibt in die schoko
variante hier habe ich die zutaten mix
exklusives alles ganz normale zutaten
die alle da haben müsste und zweier die
habe ich hier getrennt die sollten
sauber getrennt sein
dann habe ich hier die trockenen zutaten
mehl backen nicht den trinker kauder es
ist wichtig speisestärke und natürlich
backpulver hier habe ich zucker und
optional könnt ihr gerne noch etwas von
der extrakt dazu nehmen wir machen jetzt
zuallererst eine baiser masse wenn man
die nämlich später schon unter hebt dann
wird der teig besonders fluffig und ich
gebe jetzt dafür dass sauber getrennte
eiweiß in die rührschüssel meiner
küchenmaschine ihr könntet auch euer
handrührgerät verwenden aber dann
braucht ihr ein bisschen länger
wichtig ist wie gesagt das muss sauber
getrennt sind ist da auch nur ein
bisschen alge drin
dann schlägt sich das einfach nicht mehr
auch und dann müsst ihr wieder von vorne
anfangen
ihr könnt auch alternativ gerne die eier
immer wieder mal schlagen in einer
separaten schlüssel und dann erst in
eine große schüssel geben und habt ihr
keine verschwendung
so und jetzt schlage ich das so ungefähr
45 sekunden oder eine minute gibt dann
die hälfte des zuckers dazu und dann
weitere zwei minuten auf höchster stufe
steif schlagen
[Musik]
und die masse ist schön stand fest ich
habe jetzt gerade machen prise salz
rhein gegeben weil erstens hilft salz
ist die altersstruktur ein bisschen
schneller zerstört wird und andererseits
ist er bei süßen sachen immer eine prise
salz und bei herzhaften sachen immer
eine prise zucker man rundet das auch
zusätzlich noch mal den geschmack ab und
die hälfte des zuckers hat eben bewegt
dass es so schön standfest wie jetzt
ansonsten wenn ihr kein zucker dazu gibt
falls ihr euch das fragt dann wäre das
eher so schaue mich fest aber nicht so
also das ist schon wirklich sehr
standfest
ich hole mir jetzt eben eine neue
schüssel und dann schlage ich einen
zusammen mit vanille extrakt wie gesagt
das ist optional und zucker ebenfalls
richtig schön schaumig
[Musik]
nach vier minuten auf höchster stufe
sieht unsere passiert so aus also sie es
richtig schön hell geworden schön cremig
ein bisschen dicker geworden und da
haben wir jetzt die biomasse unter
beginnt jetzt ein teig schaber ganz ganz
wichtig kein schneebesen mehr verwenden
weil wir wollen die luft dass die
enthalten bleibt und nehmen nicht
entweicht und daher jetzt in drei bis
vier schritte schön mit ganz viel liebe
unterheben
[Musik]
so die masse ist jetzt schon ziemlich
flüssig und da geben wir jetzt noch im
trockenen zutaten 1
die müsste vorher unbedingt 7 ich mir
einfach mein hand sieht und ich mache
das immer so ich geb nicht dass alles
komplett direkt rein sondern ich liebe
immer ein bisschen dann habe ich unter
wenn sie mich noch mal weil so könnt ihr
auch sicherstellen dass die masse von
dem gewicht nicht erdrückt wird und
nicht zu trocken wird
[Musik]
so der teig ist jetzt fertig und jetzt
müsst ihr euch nur noch entscheiden in
welcher backform backen möchte da könnt
ihr verschiedene formen nehmen
krone herr zum blumen von und dann gibt
es ja springform die benutze ich auch
sehr gerne oder torten ringer heute
nämlich mal ein tortenring und schlag
den jetzt zusätzlich nochmal in
backpapier ein das zeige ich euch jetzt
auch mal ganz kurz
[Musik]
jetzt den tortenring einfach aufs
backblech geben und ich erinnere mich
grad zurück wir hatten ja ein café
damals also wir haben sie vor fünf
jahren geschlossen
meine mutter dem keller immer torten
gebacken und die arme die hatte dann den
tortenring irgendwie gab es hier früher
nicht zumindest nicht bei uns und dann
hat für immer hier einfach nur die form
genommen hatte kein springt vom boden
mehr und hat den dann in backpapier
eingeschlagen da muss ich jetzt kommt
irgendwie dran denken na ja auf jeden
fall gibt jetzt den teig hier rein könnt
ihr jetzt noch an der oberfläche so ein
bisschen glatt streichen
und es ist auch immer hilfreich wenn ihr
euren backofen vorheizen
[Musik]
jetzt wird der teig gebacken bei 180
grad ober und unterhitze nie gesagt im
vorgeheizten backofen ca 25 minuten
macht aber auf jeden fall die stäbchen
probe bis gleich
[Musik]
nach dem backen ganz einfach zugedeckt
auskühlen lassen dann kann die
oberfläche jetzt auch nicht austrocknen
und danach könnt ist durchschneiden
zweimal dreimal ganze ihr möchtet ich
werde euch in die video beschreibungen
die ganz genauen mengenangaben
aufschreiben noch mal ganz ganz wichtige
tipps die ich da unten dann auch noch
mal hervorheben möchte damit ihr das
auch noch mal lesen könnt und was enorm
wichtig ist wenn jetzt andere größe
haben möchte eine andere höhe
dann schaut euch gern auf meiner
webseite die umrechnung tabelle an
da könnt ihr dann einfach schauen welche
größe möchte ich und dann habt ihr da
die umrechnung formel mega mega
praktisch jetzt wünsche ich euch ganz
viel freude beim nachbacken ich hoffe
ihr hattet spaß hier weg is back schule
dann sehen wir uns auch beim nächsten
video und schreibt mir gerne in die
kommentare
welches basic rezept nicht fehlen darf
welches ich gerne noch für euch abfilmen
soll
und natürlich würde ich mich freuen wenn
ihr dem wieder deutlich nach oben da
lässt und dann sehen wir uns im nächsten
video
[Musik]